Dark Phoenix continues a long X-Men franchise
tradition by bringing in heroes and villains
familiar to the comics fans as well as referencing
classic stories.
It's easy to miss them all, so here's a look
at some of the Dark Phoenix characters who
are more important than you realized.
If you haven't seen the movie, here's your
warning that spoilers are ahead.
The X-Men throw an outdoor party after they
save the endangered astronauts early on in
Dark Phoenix, where a young woman with long
blonde hair and striking blue eye markings
sings as a cloud of sparkling lights spins
in the air around and above her, choreographed
by an unseen source.
The singer is Alison Blaire, codename Dazzler,
a mutant who can transform sound into light.
As a member of the X-Men, she uses her powers
to blind enemies or to attack with bolts of
hard light.
It's fitting Dark Phoenix is the film that
introduces her, given that the X-Men attempt
to recruit her in 1980's Uncanny X-Men #130,
just five issues before the "Dark Phoenix"
story officially kicked off.
Initially named "The Disco Queen," Dazzler
would appear in Marvel Comics, and then Casablanca
Records would find a singer who would take
on the persona of the hero and produce an
actual record.
A lot of things went wrong, though, and Dazzler
went from being an interesting media experiment
to a D-lister mostly on the periphery of Marvel's
narrative.
After Jean kills Mystique, the troubled hero
travels to a remote island.
Though it's never named, it seems to be a
version of Genosha, a place that we learn
was given to Magneto and other mutants as
a homeland.
"Look.
I know who you are.
I don't want a fight."
"No, you don't."
In the comics, Genosha begins as an island
nation ruled by humans where mutants are enslaved
by the government and their abilities are
used to serve the state.
In the 1990 event "X-Tinction Agenda," the
X-Men, X-Factor, and the New Mutants join
forces and topple Genosha's corrupt government.
In 1999's X-Men #87, the United Nations gives
the country to Magneto as a mutant homeland;
under his leadership, it grows to be something
much larger than what we see in Dark Phoenix.
One of Dark Phoenix's more mysterious minor
characters is Ariki, one of the Genoshans
Magneto brings with him when he attempts to
kill Jean Grey.
His powers revolve around his long hair, which
he uses to grapple or strike opponents.
While he's initially an enemy of the X-Men,
he's arrested with the heroes and fights alongside
them in their battle against the D'Bari on
the train.
Ariki doesn't appear in the comics.
It was initially reported actor Andrew Stehlin
would be playing a different character.
IGN reported that Stehlin's character was
Red Lotus, an Australian-Chinese character
from X-Treme X-Men whose powers have nothing
to do with hair manipulation.
Not that any of it matters all that much.
Ariki essentially disappears from the movie
during the train battle.
When Professor X makes a speech after receiving
an award from the President, one of the White
House guests is Chris Claremont, a writer
whose work on the X-Men comics helped to make
them the household names they are now.
He started writing X-Men in 1975 and wrote
them continuously until 1991.
He returns to the franchise occasionally even
now.
He wrote the first Wolverine miniseries with
artist Frank Miller, and when Logan finally
got his own ongoing series, Claremont was
its first scribe.
Claremount established the foundation for
much of what we see in the films.
It was Claremont who introduced the idea that
Magneto is a Holocaust survivor and that his
actions stem from his horrific experiences
during that time.
And, of course, it was Claremont and collaborator
John Byrne who crafted "The Dark Phoenix Saga."
"We had no expectations at all when we did
the story.
We just wanted to do a really great story."
There was a lot of mystery surrounding Jessica
Chastain's character leading up to the release
of Dark Phoenix.
We now know she plays Vuk, a member of the
nearly extinct extraterrestrial race the D'Bari.
She siphons some of the Phoenix power from
Jean Grey, but eventually is destroyed before
Jean takes to the stars.
Vuk is one of Marvel's oldest supervillains,
though in the comics, she is a he.
In his first appearance way back in 1964's
Avengers #4, Vuk turns the Avengers to stone
on the order of Namor the Sub-Mariner, who
promises to retrieve Vuk's crashed spaceship
in return.
Little was heard from the character until
Phoenix destroyed his homeworld in 1980's
Uncanny X-Men #135.
He's since made sporadic appearances using
the name Starhammer, and is usually intent
on getting revenge on Phoenix.
Nightcrawler is clearly not ready for what
he experiences in Dark Phoenix.
He suffers terrible guilt when he's forced
to leave Jean behind in the space shuttle.
"Where's Jean?
Where is she?
JEAN!"
Once Jean goes bad, the blue elf is helpless
against her.
Phoenix beats him up a couple of times, and
she doesn't pull her punches.
In the battle against Magneto and his followers
in New York City, Nightcrawler is stressed
to his limits as the rest of the team calls
on him for aid.
When a guard who is trying to help him is
killed by one of the D'Bari on the prison
transport train, he finally snaps and we see
an uncharacteristic viciousness.
He uses more brutal tactics than we've ever
seen from him, ultimately teleporting one
of the D'Bari to the train tracks, giving
her an evil grin, and teleporting away before
the approaching train kills his enemy.
He's not quite the violent, alternate-universe
version of Kurt from the comics, but he's
got that vibe.
We don't see or hear much from Selene in Dark
Phoenix.
We know she's good with knives and psychic
powers strong enough at least to hold Professor
X at bay.
And in spite of her earlier mission of killing
Jean Grey, she sacrifices herself fighting
the D'Bari.
Selene from the source material is much more
complex.
She was once known as the Black Queen of the
Hellfire Club and one of the world's most
powerful mutants, in part because of her wide
range of powers.
She can suck the life force out of others
to make herself stronger, and along with the
telepathic powers she shows in Dark Phoenix,
she's also telekinetic.
She's also very tough to kill.
No one knows how long she's been alive, only
that's it's been for millennia.
More than any other X-Men film, Dark Phoenix
reveals the shameful manipulations of the
seemingly benevolent Professor X.
Not only did Xavier lie to Jean when he told
her that her father was dead, but without
anyone else's knowledge, he placed psychic
blocks in her mind to protect her from traumatic
memories.
The Phoenix Force tears those blocks down
once it inhabits Jean.
"You think you can fix me."
"Jean, you are not broken."
Xavier being a manipulative jerk is nothing
new to the comic fans.
Over the years, characters who were once almost
fanatically loyal to Xavier begin to lose
trust in their mentor.
One of the more infamous examples of Professor
X's dishonesty comes during Joss Whedon's
run on Astonishing X-Men.
When the X-Men's technologically miraculous
Danger Room comes alive and attempts to kill
the team, it comes to light that Professor
X knew the Danger Room had a mind of its own
ever since it went online, but kept its life
a secret so no one would object to using it
to train.
Total jerk move, Professor.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit that
bell so you don't miss a single one.